Speaker 1: bad news for Herschel Walker. We're
still waiting on new Herschel Walker polling,
I think, although we'll take a look in a moment as
to whether we have new polling. Herschel Walker,
it turns out, urged his girlfriend to have a
second abortion. She says to The New York Times,
this is reported by CNBC. So remember
the story here was that early last week,
this scandal broke where in Georgia, Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker, who claims to
be against abortion. In all cases, abortion is
murder. No exceptions for incest, rape, life
of the mother, not none of it. None of it. Turns
out that he was accused credibly with receipts of
urging and then paying for an ex-girlfriend of
his to get an abortion because it would have
been inconvenient. Remember, abortions, murder,
rape, incest, no inconvenience was a legitimate
reason for him to urge and then pay for a woman
to get an abortion. The new report is he actually
urged her to get a second abortion and she didn't.
CNBC writes A woman who accused Herschel Walker of
paying for her abortion in 2009 revealed he urged
her to end a second pregnancy per the New York
Times. The woman said their relationship ended
after she refused to have the second procedure.
According to the report, the Trump backed Georgia
Republican running to unseat Raphael Warnock,
has denied paying for an abortion. That denial
is not particularly credible at this point in
time. Walker has denied knowing who the woman
is, despite reporting from both the Times and
The Daily Beast that she's the mother of a son
she had with Walker. So I believe there's four.
I don't have it in front of me, but I believe
that there's four women, at least with whom he
has had children. You would think that he would
say, well, if it's one of those four women,
I must know who it is. It's all crazy. And the
question now is, will this end the candidacy?
We still don't have any new polling. I hope
by tomorrow or later today, there will be
new polling taken after the scandal started. He
should be done. Whether he will be is unclear
because many of these Georgia Republicans are
rationalizing the whole thing and saying, well,
he would still ban abortion. He fine. He went and
paid for one, but he would still vote to ban it.
Let's see what the new polling shows.
Raphael Warnock should be winning by 40.
They tentatively had a debate scheduled
for this Friday. Walker has reportedly
still not confirmed that he will be there.
And so we will follow that closely. And
if indeed they do have that debate, you can
be sure that I will be streaming that live.